geh mal weiter und wir freuen uns jetzt
weiter man hat man hier ist äh auch weil
es ein schwieriger Anreise war wie wir
gehört haben und da sind wir auch schon
mittendrin Herr Platz in ihrem Thema das
Chaos bei der Deutschen Bahn wie lange
haben Sie heute 18 Uhr das ist ihr
Ticket ihre Ankunft ich halte das meine
Kamera sonst ist das sogar alleine
Nummer zwischen uns beiden hier können
wir das einmal
entschuldigen aber das war ihre
Nachricht darf ich alles verraten von
Leipzig hierher fahren ist jetzt keine
so lange Strecke aber dann ist es
verspätet sich schauen Sie noch mal rein
in welche Kamera muss halten 120 Minuten
ist ja länger
da musst du durch du willst dahin
danke dass Sie sich auf die lange Reise
begeben
ihre Zeit ihre Kamera
wir sehen an diesem Beispiel ich selbst
erlebt das auch als häufiger bahnnutzer
und Bahnfahrer und auch viele andere in
unserem Land erleben täglich
Bahnverkehr kommt es zu Verspätung
häufig sind die Waggons nicht in der
richtigen Reihenfolge wenn man dann mal
drin ist dann fällt das Wort Bistro aus
und irgendwas ist immer das hinter einem
einen wenn man an die Bahn denkt und die
Bahn ist leider im Moment häufig keine
Alternative zum Flugzeug oder auch zum
Auto dabei bräuchten wir eine starke
Schiene wer bräuchten eine zuverlässige
Bahn wir bräuchten Abläufe die
reibungslos funktionieren damit die
Menschen möglichst das Auto stehen
lassen oder nicht das Flugzeug nehmen
sondern die umweltfreundliche Bahn eine
Grundvoraussetzung dafür ist dass wir
mehr Schienen haben dass wir mehr
Kapazitäten schaffen und dafür müssten
wir schneller planen und bauen und
derzeit dauert ein durchschnittliche
schienenprojekt in Deutschland von der
Planung bis zum Bau an die 25 Jahre und
das ist einfach viel zu lang
das liegt häufig am Verbandsklagerecht
war einige Umweltverbände gegen ganz
viele auch Schienenprojekte klagen
deswegen meine Forderung das
Verbandsklagerecht muss reformiert
werden wir müssen in Deutschland
schneller Planen und Bauen im einige
Lösungsvorschläge jetzt von ihnen gehört
Frau Schubert wir kennen alle dieses
Drama bei der Bahn wie würden sie es
lösen das wäre ihr Ansatz also das Drama
kenne ich auch Dienstag von Bonn nach
Berlin 8 Stunden da war ich weniger
erbaut liegt an der Streckensperrung
zwischen Hannover und Berlin ich glaube
es wurde unter wundert mich ein bisschen
dass sie sich so aufregen 10 Jahre hatte
die CSU das Verkehrsministerium geführt
sie hatten also unmittelbar oder ihre
Fraktionsgemeinschaft unmittelbar
politische Verantwortung für die Bahn
weil ich teile Ihre Ziele möglichst
viele Menschen auf die Bahn zu kriegen
damit sie ihr Auto stehen lassen oder
nicht mit dem Flugzeug fliegen ich
glaube das hat es ist zum Teil der
Tatsache geschuldet dass sehr lange die
Bahn kaputt gespart wurde das viel zu
lange an der Infrastruktur gespart wurde
dass der Wert eines mit öffentlichen
Nahverkehrsunternehmens das tatsächlich
sozusagen das Herzstück das Rückgrat des
des Verkehrs ist zu lange unterschätzt
worden ist und wir jetzt sozusagen die
Zeche zahlen und die Infrastruktur
marode ist es zu lange dauert bis dann
auch neue Infrastruktur gebaut ist bis
neue Schienenwege gebaut sind es ist im
nahverkehrsbereich
regionalverkehrsbereich sehr sehr viel
stillgelegt worden so dass also ganze
Regionen mit der Bahn gar nicht mehr
erreichbar sind ich glaube da haben wir
einen großen nachhole Bedarf und der
muss jetzt organisiert werden und ich
glaube es ist sinnvoll dass das dann
tatsächlich auch die Bahn in
öffentlicher Eigentümerschaft in die
Hand nimmt damit es wieder funktioniert
also verständlichung
ist ein öffentliches Unternehmen
und das finde ich gut so aber es muss
sie muss halt auch gut geführt werden
oder weil beispielsweise
in einer Aktiengesellschaft überführen
wollte um sozusagen auf den Tag kaputt
ja das Video getrieben hat das ist nicht
die Aufgabe einer eines öffentlichen
Unternehmen seines öffentliches
Unternehmen hat dafür zu sorgen dass die
Menschen sicher von A nach B kommen aber
sie tun ja jetzt so überall wenn was für
staatlicht wird und die Unternehmen
staatliche Hand sind alles super wäre
das kann man nun wirklich nicht aus der
Geschichte herauslesen ich glaube das
Gegenteil ist der Fall also mir kommt
das immer so ein bisschen vor wenn man
ihn zuhört ja beim 157 versucht der
Platz mit dem Sozialismus irgendwie 156
mal schief gegangen aber dann klappt und
ich glaube nicht daran ich glaube es
gibt unterhalb von Sozialismus noch viel
Möglichkeiten wo es ähm deutlich wird
dass das öffentliche wichtig ist aber
sie wird eben Parteiprogramm für ein
Sozialismus natürlich ja ja
aber dafür gibt's ja Zwischenschritte
und ich bin ja gehören nicht zu denen
die sagen jetzt machen wir mal Kat und
dann ist demokratischer Sozialismus das
wird auch nicht funktionieren weil da
braucht man Mehrheiten für in der
Gesellschaft und für diese Mehrheiten zu
arbeiten zu werden das ist dafür arbeite
ich aber ich es gibt öffentliche
Unternehmen auch hier in Berlin auch
wenn es nicht glauben mögen die haben
Weltrang die Charité ist ein
öffentliches Krankenhaus seit
öffentliches Universitätskrankenhaus ist
ein spitzenforschungsort und ist auch
ein spitzenort was er wenn es darum geht
Menschen gesund zu machen weil es ein
öffentliches Krankenhaus ist und davon
gibt die BSR beispielsweise hier das
Berliner Reinigungsunternehmen ist ein
Spitzenunternehmen funktioniert ja
Vorlagen
Beispiele
viele Privatunternehmen die super
geführt wir sind und Spitzen haben also
deswegen kann man davon sieht
hier ja einig dass die Bahn nicht
funktioniert so jetzt möchte ich Ihnen
etwas erzählen ich war an diesem Sommer
unterwegs sind Frankreich in der Schweiz
und in Italien mit der Bahn und bereits
nach der deutschen französischen Grenze
merkt man wohltuend das Toiletten nicht
schmutzig sind das in den Bistros ist
nicht
sozusagen nicht nur das kälteste Getränk
was wärmstegetränk ist der kalte Kaffee
so und es gibt häufig gar nicht das
heißt das sind Verhältnisse wie früher
in der DDR ist rutscht auf Mitropa
Niveau des Ostens zurück das ist also
ein zum eine schandewein Industrieland
wie Deutschland und wir schauen nach
Italien die gleichen Erfahrungen kaum
Verspätungen guter Service es lächelt
auch mal jemand keiner der Bediensteten
läuft mit Gesicht zur Faust Gewalt durch
die typisch deutsche angeeigenschaft
woran liegt das schauen Sie heute muss
die Schweiz 60 ich wiederhole 60 Züge an
die deutsch-schweizerische Grenze
stellen um die Verspätungen Deutschland
Züge aufzufangen offiziell ich war 15
Jahre in der Schweiz also entweder sind
wir wollen jetzt sage ich Ihnen das ist
ein typisches Kennzeichen der deutschen
Krankheit und das wurde eben
angesprochen
der wird bürokratiebestimmungen Behörden
Genehmigungen zehn Jahre warten sie in
Berlin auf die Genehmigung eines
Bauantrages für ein Wohnhaus hören Sie
mal zu wie wollen die die Wohnung bauen
die sonst versprechen alles heiße Luft
der die Bürokratie erdrückt dieses Land
die ist keine wirklich freie
Marktwirtschaft auch nicht meine soziale
Marktwirtschaft der Staat mischt sich
überall ein und macht die Leute fertig
mit die klimaauflagen mit steuerauflagen
mit 1.000 Dingen kein Mensch wir werden
uns noch wundern wenn keiner investieren
will
Hamburg ein bisschen was davon erzählen
Aluminiumwerke und andere die wir alsf
dass wir jetzt Wiedersehen das heißt wir
haben eine Industrie Flucht merkt nur
keiner weil die Leute gehen dahin wo
sich besser wirtschaften lässt nämlich
in die USA so schnell gebaut wird ne das
ist nämlich der entscheidende Punkt also
wir brauchen wirklich im Durchschnitt
wir reden jetzt nicht über einen
extremprojekt im Durchschnitt bei 25
Jahre bis ein neues Team Projekt fertig
ist und das ist einfach viel zu lange
also er kann man und es gibt grüne
Umweltverbände die in sonders reden
sagen mehr auf die Schiene verlagern und
die Schiene stärken und die dann gegen
diese Projekte Klagen
der hat gesagt ein recht
Wege stark es ist wirklich stark jetzt
zu schützen wir Gott sei Dank bei den
Windrädern weil das irgendwo ist
verkürzen wir die einspruchspflichten es
ist also der Rechtsweg wird hier ein
sozusagen entrümpelt aber man sieht ja
gar keinen Wille ist es auch ein Weg und
bei der LG in falsche
Infrastruktur hat man es geschafft da
hat man den wenigen Monaten die
Infrastruktur aufgebaut und so was ich
mir wünsche ist der Wille in der Politik
dafür kämpfe ich bei Eltern mir das auch
bei der Schienen bekommen ist es auch
gegangen genau
das sind doch eigentlich so
Eigenschaften Pünktlichkeit die schreibt
man Deutschland so zu alles funktioniert
gut und dann kann jeder von uns wir
sitzen hier an einem Tisch eine
Geschichte erzählen wir zehn Stunden von
A nach B gebraucht hat wie wird das ob
sie das machen ich kann das bestätigen
die Schweizer Bundesbahnen haben
offiziell Protest eingelegt bei der
Deutschen Bahn über die Verspätungen
weil die Anschlusszüge die dort in Basel
warten
ja plötzlich Schlange stehen müssen und
der richtige zum richtigen zugeordnet
werden muss
bei den Schweizern ist das wirklich so
dass man den nachsagt die Pünktlichkeit
da gibt es so viele Dinge die die
Reinlichkeit die Sauberkeit ich habe
damals Spaß weil sie mal gesagt die
Schweiz ist so sauber die war schon
sogar das Geld das kann nicht so gut an
Fußballfelder gepflegt ja
und wenn und wenn ich mir das jetzt
anschaue ich bin seit ich bin seit 15
seit acht Jahren wieder da und habe vier
Jahre in Berlin gewohnt ich war toll ne
sie waren das reine Chaos das reine
Chaos ich bin damals gekommen ich
brauchte ein Personalausweis ich
brauchte ein Führerschein ich brauchte
eine autoanmeldung ich brauchte Gott sei
Dank muss ich nicht mehr heiraten
ja keinen Termin bekommen auf dem
Standesamt ich war schon glücklich
verheiratet bin ist immer noch alles
andere
vorstellbar
unvorstellbar ich bin Bezirk am Mitte
Bürgeramt Mitte da waren zwei ganz liebe
Damen die haben mir beide erklärt weil
ich gesagt habe jetzt kann die mich Gott
sei doch doch von der Glotze das hilft
dir manchmal das Gesicht nicht immer und
die alte sagt doch daran die Welt das
war eine sexy doch den Fan von ihnen
Piktogramm und dann habe ich jetzt
plötzlich Privilegien da gehabt die ich
auch genutzt habe muss ich dazu sagen
ich habe dann alles ein bisschen
schneller bekommen dann habe ich aber
schon mir erlaubt zu sagen das gibt's
doch nicht was ihr HIER Ihr habt hier 9
Puls
und ihr seid zu zweit dann hat er gesagt
das hat der wo wie kaputt gespart also
zusammengelegt hatte dann habe ich das
alles gelernt ich sage Ihnen was wenn
Berlin die Hauptstadt dieser Stadt jetzt
kommt diese Wahl Wiederholung ich
wünsche Ihnen persönlich alles Gute ihre
Partei nicht
die Wahlwiederholung wie die in der Welt
ankommt weh das wäre in Budapest
passiert oder in Warschau passiert da
hätten sich die Links grünen Medien hier
das Maul zerrissen darüber aber in der
deutschen Hauptstadt das ist
Bananenrepublik Artikel es gibt einen
Unterschied zur anderen Republik der ist
noch das Wetter besser okay
einmal zusammen der Gleichmut mit denen
die Berliner Politik dieses Desaster
hingenommen hat mal ebenso
freie Wahlen entschuldigen Sie die
schämen sich ja das muss gezwungen
werden dass die beiden ich mache ihn
jetzt nicht noch unbedingt besser
zusammen aber wenn ich kurz mal
nächsten Thema gerne beim nächsten Thema
selbstverständlich also einmal Berlin
verteidigen ja also
was
ihnen passiert ist auf dem Bürgeramt das
ist da arbeiten wir in Berlin jetzt
schon seit vielen Jahren dran das ist
schneller funktioniert da ich aber auch
eng verbunden bin mit Bonn weil meine
Familie da wohnt kann Ihnen sagen da ist
es auch nicht besser da dauert es
genauso lang und da gibt's
wahrscheinlich viele grüne oBI ist
frisch also das war auch schon vorher
schon so also insofern ich glaube es ist
in vielen großen Städten so das ist im
Moment sehr schwierig ist in den
öffentlichen in den öffentlichen
gespannt in den öffentlichen Verwaltung
schnell die Bürgerdienste schnell
bringen das musste man glaube ich
tatsächlich eben noch kein
großes sagen das war auch tatsächlich
ein völliges Chaos
40 Minuten warten bis ich meine Stimme
abgeben durfte jemand von ihnen
Verantwortung übernehmen das kann nicht
sein der rot-grüne Senat stellt sich
jetzt schon wieder warum sagt man soll
nicht so schlimm weil es irgendwie
vermockt worden wir sind alle im Februar
normal in gehen also das ist wirklich
unglaublich es hat niemand gesagt das
ist nicht so schlimm sondern alle haben
gesagt das ist einfach alles
gibt doch noch klare fahrverantwort